très volontaires se sont réunis à saint
germain en laye pour la youth week
c'était une une journée d'informations
et de témoignages sur les programmes qui
composent le corps européen de
solidarité
donc c'est l'un des deux dispositifs
européens qui sont qui sont mis en
oeuvre en france par l'agencé rasmusson
plus jeunesse et sports le corps
européen de solidarité quand européen de
solidarité qui permet notamment à des
jeunes de partir en volontariat pour une
durée qui peut aller jusqu'à un an dans
un autre pays européen ou même dans un
pays voisin de l'europe
beaucoup de jeunes volontaires ou
anciens volontaires qui sont
ambassadeurs du programme et qui ont
pour mission de d'informer les autres
jeunes de l'existence de ce programme
est d encourager aussi à vivre une
expérience de mobilité en europe ou à
l'international
sam prêt à accueillir de nouveaux jeunes
donc si toute personne qu'il a déjà
participé à un programme du corps hors
pair de solidarité sound un des volets
du caractère de solidarité est intéressé
pour nous rejoindre vous pouvez juste
nous contacter via les réseaux sociaux